we have some major MCU phase for leaks
today as some photos for Marvel's what
if Disney Plus series have been leaked
online how's it going everybody it's
Warren and marvels what-if series come
in to Disney Plus is probably one of the
most interesting series that we are
expecting now it is going to be animated
but the original actors who play the
characters in the MCU will be voicing
their characters in the what-if series
and the show's going to do exactly what
the title says that it's going to do
it's going to take us through a lot of
what if MCU scenarios for example one
that has been leaked that I'll talk
about in this video is a what-if black
panther was actually star-lord a crazy
scenario but will no doubt make for a
good episode of Marvel's what-if show so
we have eight leaked photos to talk
about from Marvel's what-if show big
shout out to multiverse a channel that
I'm really happy to be a part of that
has some great people and some great
content they were the first people to
get this out yesterday for an awesome
breakdown be sure to go check out the
original video in the link up above so
the first image that we have here is of
a skinny Steve Rogers before the Super
Soldier Serum shielding his eyes from
some type of light looks like it's
possibly an explosion as you can see he
himself in this moment looks like he is
about to go under to receive the Super
Soldier Serum it's unclear what this
light could be but what it could be
could be the light from Peggy Carter
receiving the Super Soldier Serum
herself remember it's a what-if series
and we already know that one of the
episodes is going to be about what if
Peggy Carter was Captain America and one
of the photos that was leaked does look
like her as a soldier most likely with
the Super Soldier Serum and then we have
Bucky the Winter Soldier who appears to
be staring at something in confuse
mminton X photo could be what he's
staring at a zombie Captain America now
we know that there's going to be a
what-if zombie series they did this in
the comics as well and as we can clearly
see from this leaked photo Captain
America is the zombie here this was also
revealed when Marvel released their
official logo for the what-if series you
could see a zombie in the background so
that's definitely going to be one of the
more interesting episodes of the what-if
series now for the next photo we have
Steve Rogers in a robot now at first
glance we don't really know what this
robot is but if we look at this other
picture it's clear that it is a type of
Iron Man armor now two things are
probably going on here one is it's a
scenario that is probably a what if
Captain America was never frozen in the
ice and the second is this is probably
an Iron Man armor that Howard Stark made
not Tony Stark's because he wouldn't be
born in this time and if he was born
he'd still be a little kid but this
definitely resembles the Mach 1 and we
can see Captain America riding on top
and then the last two photos are what I
mentioned in the very beginning at first
glance it looks like star-lord but the
second photo reveals that star-lord is
actually Black Panther as star-lord this
is a super interesting and very creative
scenario one that I'm actually really
looking forward to seeing play out in
Marvel's Disney Plus what-if series so
that is it for these leaked photos for
Disney's what-if series let me know what
you think about them are you excited for
this series or are you a little bit
weirded out I definitely think it's
going to be interesting but let me know
what you think also a reminder about my
giveaway if you'd like a chance to win
an Xbox one or ps4 be sure to subscribe
to my channel like the video and comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
I'm picking a winner at 500,000
subscribers don't forget to follow me on
Twitter and Instagram and as always
thank you all so much for watching
wolf wolf